Speaker 1: Ron DeSantis donors are increasingly
worried that he can't handle a national campaign
for the Republican nomination, particularly
against Donald Trump. And I have to tell you,
the evidence is increasingly pointing that way.
Think for a moment we're going to get into the
data and the concerns from DeSantis donors in a
moment, but think for a moment. On the one hand,
you have Ron DeSantis. He's got a new book. He's
speaking all over the country. He's going to
Staten Island and he's going to Manhattan and he's
going all over the place, speaking everywhere,
being interviewed, getting tons of positive press
from Fox News. And his polling is going down.
And meanwhile, you have Donald Trump
potentially going to get arrested any day
holding a rally on the 30th anniversary of the
Waco siege in Waco, Texas, fomenting violence,
all of this stuff. And his polls are going
up despite middle of the night, all caps,
rants on truth, social and so on and so forth.
That doesn't look good for Ron DeSantis. And this
is indeed the concern among many DeSantis donors.
There's a good NBC News article, Ron DeSantis
Donors and Allies question if he's ready for 2024.
At a recent gathering of 16 prominent Republicans,
a number of DeSantis supporters discussed if he
should run against Trump or wait until 2028 and
that 2028 question we've increasingly been talking
about. Many of you have emailed me and said
DeSantis, although he looks like he's almost 60,
he's only 44 years old. He could wait. He could
wait until 2028 when there will be no Trump. He
could even wait until 2032 if he wanted to. It's
not clear that with the higher polling he would be
willing to do that. But if the polling declines,
maybe he would. NBC News writes Ron DeSantis may
be missing his moment. A number of his donors and
allies are worried. His recent stumbles suggest he
may not be ready for a brutal fight against Donald
Trump. Some feel DeSantis needs to accelerate his
timeline to run for the Republican nomination and
begin directly confronting Trump if he is to have
any chance of thwarting Trump's momentum. Others
believe DeSantis should still sidestep Trump
altogether and wait until 2028. It is true
that with the anticipation having built for months
and months now, Donald Trump having announced in
the days right after the November of 22 midterms
and actively campaigning at this point, his first
rally was over the weekend and we'll talk about
that. How long can dissenters build anticipation?
At the beginning, you can accurately say he's
building anticipation and he's polling strongly
as he starts to misstep, as his lack of charisma
oozes out of every pore and as his polling starts
to sort of drift down. We can no longer call
it building anticipation. It's something else.
And maybe it is missing the moment. The article
continues at a Sunday luncheon. It's not a lunch.
It's a luncheon. And that's how you know it's
serious business. At a Sunday luncheon following
the annual Red Cross ball in Palm Beach, Florida.
A group of 16 prominent. Republicans described by
one attendee as a mix of DeSantis backers
and Trump skeptics discussed misgivings
about DeSantis as standing for the future if
he tussles with the former president. Quote,
They liked him. Many of them might even support
him. But they thought on balance that his long
term future was better without him trying to
take Trump head on. He will get scarred up.
The article mentions some specific donors,
including billionaire shipping goods magnate
Richard Yul Yulin and his wife Elizabeth,
whose $500,000 in combined contributions
make them among the most generous
donors to Desantis's 2022 campaign.
A person familiar with the strategy around Yulin
Spending said that right now, quote, The breaks
are pumped. The polling really made different
people pause. A spokesperson for the U. Line's is
declining to comment. It is absolutely true that
the polling has no beauty to write home about. If
you look at recent polling, you do see that it's
very solid for Trump in just about every way. Very
recent Harris Harris poll has Trump 12 ahead of
DeSantis, and that's one that's one of Desantis's
better standings. To be perfectly frank, a
premise poll has Trump 24 ahead of DeSantis
among registered voters and 30 ahead among all
respondents. A YouGov poll has Trump 15 ahead
of DeSantis. Now, the counter point is DeSantis
hasn't even announced yet. And having numbers this
strong when you're not even running suggests that
if DeSantis announces he's going to get a surge,
a boost, a swelling for lack of a better term, of
his polling, that may be the case. The problem is,
as I mentioned, that's a stronger argument before.
Everybody's talking about DeSantis for four months
and he's doing interviews and book tours and
speeches and getting the best possible press he
can get from Fox News. Once you have months and
months of that, it starts to feel as though his
potential is increasingly baked into existing
polling and there's less of a boost to be had
with an announcement. So I don't know what's going
to happen. It's not for me to advise Republicans,
nor is anybody asking me to advise Republicans.
But my concern for DeSantis from day one has
been his lack of charisma and seeming desire to be
above Trump When he's asked while Trump said this
what he use and he says, I don't spend my time
criticizing Republicans, fine. That may that may
play well in Florida. But it's not striking me
as the strongest positioning for fighting Trump
in a national campaign. I want to hear from you.
What do you think about DeSantis chances as we are
about to enter April of 2023? Are they deflating?
Can they still be pumped up? Let me know what you
think in a comment. We'll follow up and see
what's on your minds. The David Pakman Show
continues to be funded primarily by our audience.
We have something called the membership program,
so you get perks in exchange for your support.
You can sign up at join Packman dot com. We do
an extra show every day for our members. We also
provide commercial free audio and video streams of
the show for you much earlier in the day than the
show is otherwise published as well as invitations
to the members only town hall events and a private
soundboard for our members where you get the vast
majority of the clips I have on my soundboard.
Speaker 2: The United States will be
the first nation to land an astronaut on Mars.
Speaker 1: If you want to go to Mars yourself,
yes. Also, another member benefit.
You can sign up at Joint PAC MEDCOM